people want to  look successful more than actually be  successful the reason i focus on love  and being kind to yourself and the [ __ ]  that i've been talking about is that's  the seed of the whole game if you need  lambos and chains and accolades and  check marks and a million followers to  clog the holes that you have in your  soul then you're gonna not be able to  build meaningful things because you're  taken out most people are addicted with  buying something to make themselves feel  better to close a gap in their soul  to impress others because they're  insecure people's intent is selfish  because they're trying to plug holes my  mother in my circumstance plugged my  holes before they started so i'm a grown  up with no holes of course i have holes  but like  [ __ ] a lot less than a lot of people  [ __ ] it let me go  close other people's holes